trop 20% des artistes
[Musique]
à cause de leur manque de choses hein
vous verrez ferrée pour ceux qui
regardent l'émission des musulmans vous
faites par ou de travail ya 70% dans
chaque émission
[Musique]
fini a alors fini c'est alors ils ont
permis de déterminer comment
vraiment la politique termine comme ça
vous avez vous terminé
et deuxième chose regardez aussi les la
regarder tous les autres pays qui font
un agréable talent il ya aussi beaucoup
d'étrangers dedans parce que le but
n'est pas de mettre que des français
c'est pas une mission nationale
le but c'est aussi ça s'appelle le monde
la france a sélectionné mais alors nous
un peu du crâne en ukraine y avait des
français des anglais des skis s'est
retournée prions un délai au direct et
ça c'est vous qui avez fait mouche c'est
vous qui avez insultés madame nakamura
mais si j'étais vous je tairai vous est
discrédité pour donner votre opinion
quand vous parlez de la france un à
creil talent c'est un scandale caroline
a raison y'a que des ukrainiens des
russes et alors alors à tous quoi ils
disent qu'ils vont chercher des gens
dans les territoires français
c'est faux franchement matthieu
delormeau contentez vous de ce que vous
connaissez vous taire merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on va voir interdire expédièrent moi je
la dois à tous les tuer isabelle essayer
d'avoir un tout petit peu de juges et
autres
revenez les pieds sur terre et dites
vous que le vrai titre c'est la crème
talent sans ce passage en force
voilà ça c'est ce que j'aurais aimé ça
justement j'avais fait dire nous
laissons ça s'exprime normal alors allez
c'est bon ça va le melon invasif ça
suffit suffit pas et il ya une tournée
régionale pour effectuer talents en
france vous regardez dans cabaret 80%
des artistes
[Applaudissements]
ça te dit me taire et faire entendre
votre histoire est tous les horizons
moi je veux plus te voir tourner moi
vous c'est le seul sur ce plateau il n'a
pas compris qu'on le voulait fait lui
c'est pour ça que vous êtes comme sage
il sait pourquoi mais c'est terminé
droit retournement non c'est terminé
oui les meilleurs que toi j'ai une envie
d'être derrière vous churn alors oui
alors fini c'est avec ce que je vous dis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]